[موسيقى]
انه اسبوع فضائي بامتياز وبالتحديد اسبوع
القمر والعوده الى القمر تقودها الولايات
المتحده بعد اكثر من 43 عاما من هبوط
ابولو لكن هذه المره ليست لوحدها على سبيل
المثال المستكشف راشد اطلقته الامارات
بغرض الهبوط على سطح القمر من المفترض
يهبط في ابريل 20 23 لكنه ليس الخبر
الوحيد المتعلق بالفضاء هذا الاسبوع اطلقت
شركه ايسبيس اليابانيه الخاصه الناشئه
لتكتب اول وجود اليابانيه على القمر
المقبل اما الملياردير الياباني
الذي سافر في رحله لمحطه الفضاء الدوليه
خلال العام الماضي كان اعلن عن ذهابه في
مهمه سياحيه الى القمر وابدا حاجته رفقه
بالفعل تنافس نحو مليون شخص لذهاب في رحله
الذهاب والاياب قبل ان يعلن ميزه واخيرا
عن قائمه المحظوظين التي تضم
اشخاص من دول مختلفه على كل حال من واشنطن
تطلعنا زميلاريد سليمان على تفاصيل عوده
الولايات المتحده للقمر
[موسيقى]
تحديات تونسيه منافسات اقتصاديه ها هي
امريكا تسلك مجددا طريقه جارنا القمر
التمس واحد اسمه البرنامج الذي وضعته
اجزاؤه ثلاثه تنتهي عام 2025 ولكن هذه
المره لا تعود الولايات المتحده وحيده الى
القمر بل ما عدد من الدول مثل السعوديه
والامارات والبحرين التكلفه مئه مليون
دولار
[موسيقى]
هذه الدبلوماسيه العلميه قوت وضع الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها واظهرت الحلفه المركزا
للتقدم العلمي لا يمكن اقصائه خاصه بظل
السباق نحو الفضاء الذي اعلنت عنه كل من
الصين وروسيا
اما الجانب الاقتصادي فهو السبب الاخر
لسباق الولايات المتحده الى القمر
الهيليوم من القمر تحوي الارض من هذه
الماده على عده كيلوجرامات فقط اما تربه
القمر فيعتقد انها تحتوي على ما يقدر
بمليون طن منها بسبب التفاعل المباشر مع
اشعه الشمس عبر ملايين السنين
في تطوير الصور اكثر امنا وارخص بفارق
واسع من التفاعلات النوويه ومن ثم توفير
قدرا هائل من الطاقه
حسنا اهتمام الولايات المتحده بالقمر ليس
محصورا بحرف موارده الطبيعيه فقط الامر
اعمق من ذلك بكثير بل يتعده الى المصلحه
العسكريه خاصه مع تاسيس قوه الفضاء
الامريكيه قبل السنوات بدات تتضح رؤيه
مهمه هذه الكتيبه من الجيش الامريكي مع
حديثي الجيشين الامريكي والصيني عن اجراء
عمليه عسكريه خارج مدار الارض للسنوات
[موسيقى]
التي تتمكن اولا من السيطره على كم من
هائل من الموارد الفضائيه سوف تمتلك اقوى
اقتصاد في العالم بلا شك ولكن تبقى
القوانين التي ستنظم وجود كل هذه الدول
وسباقها غامضه ما عدم تحديد معاهده الفضاء
الخارجي عام
1967 تفاصيله وقوانين العمل في الفضاء وكل
ما ذكرته انذاك اعتبار القمري والمجرات
السماويه الاخرى متاحه للاستكشافي
والاستخدام
لصباح العربيات سليمان واشنطن
كليزمان مراد
وعانقه الفضاء والوصول الى القمر من قبل
دول سياسيا اليوم بدنا نتحدث عن اسباب
اقتصاديه لمعانقه الفضاء حدثنا اكثر عن
السر من وراء هذا الاهتمام العالمي
بالفضاء والقمر
انه سؤال جيد جدا
[موسيقى]
لتنضم الى مهام استكشاف القمر هناك عدد
كبير ايضا من الدول التي تاتي لتنضم الى
هذا الانجاز العلمي او هذه الطريقه
العلميه للوصول والعوده للقمر
بشكل بشكل
مثال المهمه الاماراتيه همم تظهر ما يمكن
للمهام المستقبليه ان تقوم به في المستقبل
رغم ان رحلات الفضاء ستخدم البشريه من
الفضاء الى الارض ماذا عن العكس من الارض
الى الفضاء هل السياحه الفضائيه قادمه
هي الحدود الجديده لما يقوم به الانسان ما
يجب ان نقلبه حاليا هو في وضع همم اختباري
جدا ونحن في مرحله الاختبارات هناك الكثير
من الحديث عن السياحه الفضائيه ولكن
السياحه الفضائيه لا تزال في مرحله
الطفوله جدا نحن في الخطوات الاولى سنرى
في المستقبل مجموعه من الخدمات السياحيه
التي تاتي باسعار مرتفعه جدا ولكن التي
تاتي بشيء من
الخدمات التي تاتي بالكثير من الاهتمام
عالميا انها منتجات فضائيه
ان تحصل عليها همم وهناك الكثير من الامور
الاخرى التي يمكن ان تاتي من هذه الحدود
الجديده التي تحدد في الفضاء وهذا امر
مثير جدا ومهم جدا للبشريه
طيب خطط القوى العالميه لبناء قطاع فضائي
مستدام هل يمكن لهذه الخطط انت النور
وتخدم البشريه والارض في انواع واحد
زمن التمويل الحكومي الحصري للفضاء انتهى
ذلك الزمن انتهى وهناك اهتمام كبير وهناك
تنافس كبير بين امريكا والاتحاد السوفيتي
في الماضي دافع باتجاه هذه الاكتشافات
ولكن حصلت الكثير من الانجازات التقنيه
والتكنولوجيه التي كانت السريه
لهذا الدفاع الجديد نحو الفضاء ونحو القمر
بالتحديد
المثال تاتي ايضا
لجين اقتصاديه هناك الكثير من ال ال
الطموحات للدول المتختلفه ان كان القوى
العالميه الكبرى مثل الولايات المتحده
ولكن القوى الجديده التي يمكن ان تستفيد
من هذا الامدفاع مثل الامارات واليابان
وانا اتوقع المزيد من الدول التي صد النظم
الى ذلك
شكرا لك